Denise Brosseau, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm very well, Michael.
Nice to talk with you.
I'm so excited to hear about your journey
and the different organizations
that you're a part of.
We're not gonna be able to talk about
everything that you've done
even though I want to talk
about everything
because it's so, so cool.
Besides the fact that you were a lecturer
at Stanford Business School
and you were honored
as a Champion for Change
by the White House.
And you were, I think,
named one of 100 most influential women
in Silicon Valley as well.
So, a lot to talk about definitely,
but before we dive into
two specific wonderful organizations
you're a part of,
Futuro Health and Vote by Design,
both related to Stanford,
I'd love to hear a little bit
about yourself.
And you mentioned to me
that you started your first company
at the age of 26.
And I'd love to understand a little bit
about your life journey and what led you
to do all the awesome things that you do.
By the way, one of the most awesome things
that I found was that you are on the board
of a local theatre company,
right, in the Bay Area
which won the Tony Award.
It did.
And it's been such a pleasure.
You never think
I've been a huge theatergoer
my whole life
and to get invited to serve on this board
was such a dream.
And then, literally right after I joined,
they won the Tony
and so sure, I'll take credit.
Are you more interested in plays
or in musicals for theater?
It's both, which I love.
It's three musicals every year
and four standard plays.
And so, it's the best
of all possible worlds.
All right. So, I have to know
your favorite musical?
Oh, my goodness.
That's not a fair question.
It's like choosing
between a mother and a father.
A musical you love?
I will go back to my earliest days.
I think the first musical
I ever fell in love with
was The Sound of Music.
And just recently, I went back
and watched the movie.
I had not seen it in decades.
And so, what a pleasure to realize
that musical really stands up over time.
100%. It's timeless.
Okay. So, going back to your journey.
You're starting a company
at the age of 26
and walk me through some of your path.
Well, I started my career
really very eclectic,
had no idea what I wanted to be
when I grew up.
But I moved out to California
after coming out here on a business trip
and sort of stumbled my way
into the tech industry.
And my first company went under quickly
after I had joined it.
And while I was there, I fell in love
with this Macintosh computer.
And so, I ended up going into
another consumer software company,
which I loved, but on the side,
I started this
Macintosh consulting business
and started helping install computers
and train people on computers
and ended up making more money
in my little side business
than I did in my day business
which was fine 'cause it was really
where my heart was.
And it was actually that experience
that really pushed me
to go to business school,
to go back to Stanford and get my MBA,
because I was thinking
I love this little company,
but I don't know how to scale it.
I just had no real understanding
of what it took to do that next step.
And so, when I went back to get my MBA,
it was with that entrepreneurship goal,
but also I did a focus in non-profits.
And so coming out of Stanford,
I went back into the tech industry,
but on the side
I started a nonprofit organization
with a bunch of friends.
And it was really the culmination
of both of those loves,
which was an organization called
the Forum for Women Entrepreneurs,
a non-profit, and it was all about
women in venture capital.
How could I help others
who were going through
what I was going through to really scale.
How do you do that?
How do you raise venture capital?
Why would you want to?
Why would you not want to?
And then ... built this community
and grew it to seven cities
across the country.
And I helped start
the first venture capital conference
for women entrepreneurs, Springboard,
that has helped now women raise
over nine billion in capital.
So that was sort of that really joyous journey
of women's entrepreneurship.
It had its downsides; there was
economic downturns and struggles.
But then after that,
I did a little other eclectic things,
did some politics,
and then I started in really the journey
that I'm in now, which is
how do I help people make the journey
from leader to thought leader.
You actually taught a course, right,
at Stanford Business School, about that.
Yeah. That's really my passion right now
is how do I help people,
primarily women, but everybody,
really think through like what is it take
to be a thought leader,
why do you need to think about this,
why does this matter.
And so, I wrote a book on the subject.
I do a lot of consulting
and coaching and teaching
both at Stanford and on Lincoln Learning.
And that's really the work I do today.
So, talk to me a little bit
about this jump between a leader
and a thought leader.
What is that all about?
It's a wonderful question,
because I think it's been
such an overused word
and part of what I've been trying to do
in working in this field
is to recapture what I think
is the essential elements.
So, for me, leader is someone
who is really what I call,
"one to many"
They usually have control over the people
that they're interacting with,
that they're managing, they're leading
because they are in some ways
connected to these folks,
either through a direct relationship
or somewhat a matrix organization.
But when you think about
thought leadership, I think about
that as many to many;
how do you get people to take the ideas
that you're advocating
and carry them forward
to their communities.
So, it's really thinking
about this ripple effect
at how do we build change,
how do we build essential movements,
and that is really this construct
of being a thought leader.
So, it's a really different set of skills.
I mean, it's certainly
the essential elements of leaders,
but then it adds a whole set of skills,
of mostly communication skills,
about how you really move beyond that
to become a thought leader.
So for anybody watching this
that we don't have the privilege
of being in that class and going through
that journey with you,
give me some of the insights
that students taking that course
at Stanford would get
about understanding how to have this
one to many relationship as a leader.
I think it begins
with really understanding
that you can't do this in every field.
You have to really double down
and find one particular niche
that's really yours.
Someplace that you can own
and that you have some passion around.
So, it's not even just about expertise,
it is about having some driving passion
around making some change.
So I talk a lot about this
"what if" future.
So, when I was starting the Forum
for Women Entrepreneurs,
my what if future was
"What if women could have 50%
of the venture capital funding
in the United States?"
At the time, it was less than one percent
when we began, and sadly
not a whole lot has changed.
I think in a good year
we might get to four percent
or seven percent, maybe.
Really?
Yeah. No, it's been ...
We have made very little progress.
And so, your what if future
can be far, far away,
it can be something you're striving to.
But the other thing to understand,
I think the big differentiator
between leaders and thought leaders
is this idea of being clear
in developing frameworks and blueprints
and things that others can pick up
and carry forward.
It's not enough for you
to have a really cool meme
or just a message
that people can carry forward,
although I'm not saying that's not good,
that's a ... essential element,
but really having the guideposts
for others who are going
to carry your ideas to their communities.
They need to have the message, the book,
the blueprint in some way.
And so, I think that was
a key differentiator
that I was trying to teach my students.
Like what does it take to make change,
and when you've learned something,
how can you share that with others.
I love it. Okay.
And then you get honored
by the White House.
Was that for a specific project?
Did you go to the White House for that?
I did. It was quite an amazing experience.
It was under Obama,
which was a wonderful time
to be in the White House.
And I was honored for my work
with women's entrepreneurship,
whether it was through Springboard
or through the Forum for Women Entrepreneurs.
And I was nominated
and selected and we went.
There was a hundred people
who were all honored at the same time,
and we were honored
from across the United States.
And what was so magical about that day,
besides never imagined
you're gonna get honored
at the White House,
okay let's start with that.
But then, it was a whole day.
So after the ceremony,
then they actually broke us up
into working groups, and we had a chance
to sit down with people
from different networks of women
from Florida to ... Tennessee,
and I learned so much
from what these people were doing
and I was able to share some of the things
that I had also been working on.
And so, that was I think
that was the hugest gift.
Wow. That's incredible. Okay.
So, let's dive into
two wonderful organizations,
both of them making a great impact.
Let's start with Futuro Health
and then move on to Vote by Design,
which is obviously very, very relevant
to the times we live in today.
So, the Futuro Health,
talk to me a little bit about that.
Most recently, you were
the chief operating officer
of that organization.
What was the aim over there?
So, what was great about Futuro Health
is it's a very unique design
in the way it came together.
So, it was brought about by a partnership
between Kaiser Permanente
and their largest union, SEIU-UHW.
And these two organizations came together
and funded this non-profit, Futuro Health,
with $132,000,000
over the next four years.
And the focus is
how do we build the next network
as it were, or the next workforce
in education, excuse me,
the next workforce in health care.
And so what we're doing is
... the union is out there
picking up connections
through the community of all the members
that they have,
they've 100,000 members.
So, they're outreaching
to friends and family and inviting them
to come and go back to school
to become health care workers.
And then Kaiser's money is then spent
to actually support these adult learners
to go back to become medical assistants,
dental assistants, etc.
Because in California, we are looking
at a shortage, even before covid.
It was looking to be
500,000 person shortage
in health care by 2025.
What?
I know. And that kind of scared me
because I want to grow old here, right.
I want someone to be ready
to take care of me when I'm older.
So this is really,
and what's unique about it
not just, of course,
... such an enormous initiative,
but it's so unusual
for a big organization and a union
to come together. That is very rare.
But secondly, understanding that
it is very hard for an individual,
especially a low income individual,
to go back to school.
It's a year out of your life,
it's expensive.
To have an organization who not only
is gonna pay for it,
but also gonna offer you support
through that journey,
that's the really critical element
because we really want
to build our workforce,
but we can't depend on them
to be able to pay
for their own education.
We need to fund them.
And so this, I think, is a model
that we'd love to see replicated
across the whole United States.
Wow. So, give me a little bit of insight
into the actual experience
of being the operating officer over there.
What were some of the greatest challenges
you faced and some of the
interesting occurrences you had?
Well, the fun thing was
I was working with a woman
that I actually knew
through the Stanford community.
She's also a Stanford MBA.
She's a couple of years behind me,
and she also has her masters
in education.
And she was actually
headhunted by this group
to start and to be the CEO.
And she called me
I was the first person
that she brought on board week one
and we got together.
I was really the person
putting in all the infrastructure.
So, while she was doing a lot of managing
of the unbelievable amount of politics
that were involved,
I was really putting in all the
getting the bank account,
figuring out who was going to do
the accounting for us, all of that.
And then hiring the team
and finding a location up in Sacramento
where we were all located.
And then, of course, all the basics
of putting in the financials,
putting in all of the systems and processes.
So, I learned a ton.
I hadn't actually been an employee
for a long time, so ...
I'm almost always a consultant.
So, this was kind of unique for me,
but I really believe
in the mission of the organization
and I just love everything
that we were doing.
So, I did a whole year of commitment
to this, and I just left
about two weeks ago.
So, I'm really proud of what the organization,
is on its solid footing now,
and I ... feel like they're on their way,
and I really love that startup phase.
I'm not the person
who likes to be there to scale.
I really like the foundations
and getting everything done.
Unbelievable.
Okay. And then you work on
Vote by Design, working with
the design school at Stanford,
which is notorious for coming up
with innovative solutions
to all sorts of problems.
So, what is this project?
So Lisa Kay Solomon, my client,
is the founder of Vote by Design.
And she came together,
she's an entrepreneur in residence, executive in residence
over at the Design school.
And she brought together a group of folks,
whether they were design thinking folks,
neuro-scientists, educators,
they came together about a year ago
to rethink how individuals
can be empowered
to have more agency around voting.
How could you create
a civic engagement experience
for voters and would be voters
to understand what it means
to select a president?
So, just to give context into this problem
because there are a lot of people
that are watching this
that are outside of the United States.
What is the pain point that this program
is trying to solve?
Because any person would imagine
yes, there's an election.
Every person wants to vote
because we all want to select
our next leader, right?
But that's not exactly the case.
Well, that is one issue.
One is that people
don't always choose to go and vote.
They feel that their vote doesn't matter,
or they don't really have
the wherewithal
to understand what does it mean
to choose a leader of a country.
I mean most of us, we just,
we come out of high school,
we come out of college,
whatever, we go vote.
Nobody ever taught us
anything more than
okay, this is the day,
this is the place,
this is what you go do.
But the actual understanding
of how you select a candidate,
it's very easy, I think,
for all of us to be a bit lazy.
Like I'm a Democrat,
I'm just gonna vote
the Democratic ticket
or I'm a Republican.
But personally, as an independent,
I find I can't really do that.
I need to be more thoughtful.
But what ... pushing people to do
is to be more thoughtful
by creating a one to two hour
engaged experience, non-partisan,
non-issue specific, but very much
a fun interactive process for thinking
about what are you looking for
in a candidate. Like what are
the leadership characteristics
that it takes to be a president?
Ahat does it take
to be a president in a crisis?
What did it take for our past presidents,
like which ones do you think
of as successful and why?
And then really take all of that
and wrap it into a new way
of understanding how you might select
in the next election,
how you might watch
a debate differently.
Like I was watching
the campaign last night,
the fourth day of the convention
for the Democrats,
and it's just so interesting how leaders
are, introduce themselves.
But if you don't have that lens,
if you're not looking at that,
you're just looking for the slogans
or the rah rah,
you may forget that this is
selecting the leader, as we call it,
of the free world, right,
of the United States.
And that is an awesome responsibility
that we want to ...
- Of course.
So, it sounds like the solution
that is proposed here
it's less of about trying
to actively going and telling people,
"You should go vote. This is important."
But get them to actively think
intrinsically what matters to them
in a leader, and then by having them
be more thoughtful about it
and be more caring about it,
that will create the agency for them
to go and take action
and hopefully propel this
within their own community, right?
I couldn't have said it better myself.
Wonderful. So, how has this been going?
Is this something that's being active
right now as we're nearing the election?
What's been wonderful about it
is that we're being able
to get this spread across schools,
across libraries,
across community centers,
so that we've created these tools
freely available on the website,
www.votebydesign.org,
and we're giving them away
to anyone and everyone
including a facilitator guide,
all the materials you need
so that you can run these sessions.
And so we're encouraging people,
as many as possible
in high schools and above,
to run sessions like this.
And what we are finding is that
teachers love this,
community leaders love this
because it's all done for you.
You can learn how to facilitate this
in an hour. The session can be anywhere.
Yeah. Very easy to facilitate.
I participated
in one of the first sessions
and just fell in love with the whole idea
because I thought it was so clever.
And even at my age,
having voted for many years,
what was wonderful
was to have a new lens provided for me
as I make these decisions.
I honestly had never really thought
about how I choose a president.
I'd never really thought about
... more important this versus that.
So, I think that
these kinds of conversations
and this kind of engaged perspective
is what we need
to have a citizenship with agency
as you said.
I love it. And I love the scalability
because my next question was going to be
it's great to have these sessions,
but it seems that
it's not really scalable.
Bringing people together in a room,
teaching a moderator,
having a personal interaction
with the participants,
but if you're able to make this
as simple as an hour for somebody
to become a good facilitator
and then taking it to their own community
and create agency within them,
then obviously the butterfly effect
just continues from there.
That is so, so cool.
Denise, we only have
a couple of minutes left,
but I have to know
a little bit more about you
and what you're truly passionate about.
Because we're talking about
the future of health care,
running organizations.
We're talking about empowering women
and leadership position
and venture capital.
And now we're talking about politics
and giving agency to citizens,
especially young people.
What are you really passionate about?
What really motivates you?
My motivation is changing the world.
It's just as simple as that.
I want to make a difference.
I want to leave a legacy that matters,
and I think what's wonderful
about the organizations I've started is
they're all still in existence,
they're all still going strong,
and that's what it means
to be a startup person.
If you do it well, you put in the bases
that are going to allow others
to build on top of them,
and that's what I've been doing
my whole career.
So, what are some things
that I can take with me
as I go on my entrepreneurial journey?
So, I'm pretty much at the point
where you were at
when you started your first company,
and now I get to take
some of your insights and go with them.
So, what things
should I be keeping in mind
as I go on my journey
to hopefully make a positive impact
on the world?
Well, I will say
the most important thing I've learned,
if I only had one, it would be
don't build a company because it's cool
or it's the fun thing to do;
only build organizations and companies
where people already are asking
for what you are building.
So every time I've been successful,
it's because there was a need
and it was expressed.
In fact, I was usually doing
whatever it was for free
before anybody ever paid me,
because people kept calling
and needing that service
or that whatever I was trying
to put out in the world, that product.
And so, the time that I did not do that,
when I just thought it was a cool idea
and I'm just gonna go build it,
nothing happened, right.
But when I build something
people already are asking for
So I say to listen.
If you listen to the marketplace,
it tells you what is needed
and where the money lay
and where the audiences lay
and that you can just go pick those up
and go forward.
That's the best way to build a company.
Denise, thank you for being so generous
with your time.
This was wonderful.
I have one last question
and that is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Well, I would say
anybody who knows me would say
the most important thing to know is that
I'm very well connected
and I think that's part and parcel
of the life that I've built.
It's very connected
in many different communities.
I'd say the second,
which you've already picked up on, is
I'm very eclectic,
like I don't have just one thing
I'm interested in.
And then third, I'm really passionate
and energized about making change.
I love it.
Denise, thank you very, very much.
Continue doing good for the world,
and I look forward
to following your journey
and hopefully reconnecting along the way
and continue to ask
for advice and support.
So, thank you very, very much.
You're welcome, Michael.
It was great to talk with you.
You too.